you dare into this [__] house
on a Sunday it's the Lord's Day [__]
are you kidding me or what uncle Joey
the Lord's Day I'm told but whatever the
[__] it is it don't matter I want to see
nothing but [__] and [__]
elbows Tampa Florida was [__]
sensational you people are savages down
there I'll be back next year cuz I
[__] love the chickens running all
over the street and whatnot but it's all
over this week we're gonna Lexington
[__] Kentucky break the [__]
Sheep out and wash your feet uncle
Joey's coming in [__] heavy but
this is not even there this nor that
it's all about the [__] day and it's
all about the week [__] it's a whole
new set a week with a whole new set of
[__] priorities and you better
be up to it you understand me cuz we're
slinging dick and giving our [__]
slippers this week you dare enter this
[__] house anyway I'm smoking
some [__] heat tonight you understand
me we got this but raoji
named that the [__] Pablo Escobar and
we got this [__] missin fire I'm
gonna light that [__] on fire
but I hope you're great you look good
yeah I'm saying uncle Joey's here tip
top Magoo rested took a little that
little workout when I got off the
[__] plane and get the blood going
and now I'm ready for a whole new week
of [__] adventures and the best part
is you're coming with me [__] we
got the podcast tomorrow night and
Wednesday night Lexington Kentucky
Thursday and nothing but videos all week
but Joey watch what the chitter-chatter
spark this [__] number let's do this
[__] do this [__] I feel good I feel
ready for a whole new [__] week I
wrote my goals down for the week I wrote
my goals down for the [__] month I
wrote my plan out for the week exactly
how I'm doing it and now there's no
misunderstandings you understand me
everything is by-the-book for the
hundredth time
a man without a plan is not a
[__] man so get to it
uncle Michi wrote that [__] for
you philosophies out there I'm a
philosopher
take that to your [__] cookie what
our [__] God remember God country Gor
[__] or whatever the [__] direction is
it is but the most important thing this
week is you and what you're gonna do and
how they're gonna suck your
[__] dick cuz they every
morning we wake up at zero wall confused
who botched out what we're gonna do
today but you got to get your grip ste
and go out and let these [__]
know you're playing for keeps that's the
problem they don't know you're playing
for keeps
they take your [__] around won't you
play for keeps [__] like oh
this guy's not [__] around number one
I mean you got him you got him you got
him on the [__] floor they can't do
dick T remember if you prepared they got
a suck your dick if you're prepared they
got a suck your dick if you're prepared
mentally they got a suck your dick and
if you're prepared physically got a suck
your dick Schofield prepared they got a
suck your dick and that's how it goes
down in if you're a student of the
church we're [__] family we
understand me so no matter what you do
you have 9,000 coming in behind you I've
seen it already I've seen it the last
couple months and that's why I'm more
excited than [__] ever none but
[__] and elbows on a mental [__]
state you understand me
we're taking over [__] mines hard
solve the whole [__] deal cuz we
don't give a [__] when you wake up in
the morning you don't give a [__] you
understand me you wake up going who's
gonna sniff my [__] nutsack today who
there's there a line are you taking
numbers because the the [__]
knowledge I'm dropping today is on point
the Joey all fired up from the [__]
reefer spark a little bit you're right
though I've been in a [__] hotel room
for three days I'm really around
well if another smoke color could we
smoke the fire I don't even know what
the [__] we smell anything
I got dementia from this [__] leaf
reefer let's try this [__] fire and
that's it and that's that I'm hoping you
guys to prepare for whatever [__]
comes cuz I always add [__] come on you
got the pistol you got your mind and you
got your [__] nut sack and that's the
most important thing you follow me
everything else is background music who
gives a [__] about the score the game
it's your [__] score what's your
[__] score that's the most important
thing I'm still [__] behind the
8-ball and I'm [__] fighting every
day I'm still [__] - [__] points
so I can't imagine what the [__] you
doing cuz I get up in the morning like I
don't give a [__] jack and that's how
you gotta get up like you don't give a
[__] if they tell you no it's one
[__] more no closer to a yes always
remember that
oh I love smoking reefer with the church
family and saying remember I'm with you
you're with me and they want to be with
us cuz we got nothing but [__] heart
you understand me
we may not be [__] brain surgeons but
I got ten [__] but heart not
take I'll spoil my [__] my troop
would have [__] him with nine and ten
[__] been hard anyway that's it
Lexington Kentucky I can't [__] wait
this reef is killing the [__]
but at least I'm dying in the name of
something anyway tip-top Magoo as usual
because you guys in my world as long as
you guys live in my world I'm silent
like a [__] you understand me I
flew back this morning with mr. crusher
and [__] John Cena on the [__]
plane back from [__] Tampa so
it was a very nice flight
so I was happy I saw a bird at the
airport picking up his dead solid
[__]
this is out of respect for Burt for
[__] October sober October
ie the best my kick-ass old bathtub suck
my dick and call me shorty I was born in
1940 remember the church tomorrow night
at 8 o'clock Wednesday 8 o'clock and
[__] Thursday Lexington Kentucky
throw away the Bible's uncle Joey's
coming to town [__] thank you for
being family and have a great [__]
week don't take [__] from nobody tell
them all to sniff your [__] helmet
why miss uncle Joey said so but I didn't
get my metal are being on sorry
but get McConnell a he did do I look a
mess I love calling I love you
[__] stay black
have a good week don't take no [__] from
nobody and keep the eyes open always
keep the eyes